Wow this is I'm just taking this in
right now just being here it's pretty
incredible I mean I think I broke a
record my own record for holding on
holding my pee in for the longest
because I didn't want to miss a moment
today can I say pee sorry um anyways
it's an honor to be here celebrating the
work of Gene Kelly as a dancer actor
choreographer and director his
influences made impact my career but you
know unless unlike most people I didn't
grow up watching Gene Kelly uh actually
I didn't even really know who Gene Kelly
was you know wasn't exposed to many
musicals when I was a kid I was too busy
watching teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and watching transformers although that
that I could mimic transformers turning
into a car like I figured that was
somewhat like dancing but I didn't
really figured that out
at that moment um I didn't really have
any interest in dance until high school
I was a late bloomer I you know I saw
dance team in high school perform and my
friends they would make fun of me and
they want went as far as to dare me to
audition for the dance team I'm not
gonna lie wasn't the Dare that made me
want to audition it was the fact that I
could probably be in a room full of
girls and I was pretty much the perfect
place to pick up girls but I was
hesitant at first you know my football
friends would make fun of me and if I
join that would be one of those three
guys and on the team and you know the
two other guys pretty much dance like
girls so it was like do I have to dance
like girls crap doctor - exactly girls
who do it right but I proceeded to move
forward and it was one of the best
decisions of my life and once I started
as a dare to join the dance team quickly
turned into a passion now even though
the newly found passion took some
navigating to really find out who Gene
Kelly was you know my first influences
was where Michael Jackson and Usher and
Justin Timberlake right now but um after
exhausting my VHS watching the same
videos music videos and performances
over and over again I needed more and I
wanted to know who their influences were
then someone handed me a copy of singing
in the rain and that was my first time
seeing Gene Kelly dance and I was blown
away and I felt like I was being
introduced to a whole new world then I
dug deeper and uh and wanted to find
anything and everything about Gene Kelly
and it was then I found a movie called
summer stock starring Gene Kelly and
Judy Garland and we saw that tonight
there was a number where Gene Kelly was
in an empty warehouse as you saw with
creaking bore newspapers and scattered
all over the place somehow created in my
opinion one of the most magical musical
numbers ever I've ever seen I must watch
it over a hundred times and each time
taking something new away his
syncopation his masculinity his
precision athleticism and the ability to
make it seem like you could dance just
like him if you tried but then after a
couple fail attempts you knew that it
was just an illusion on how he made
everything look easy now it wasn't until
I saw Gene Kelly that I realized that
ballet could be masculine and still look
right dance wasn't just for girls and it
shouldn't be embarrassed to do it and
his influences span heavily throughout
my whole career his ability to tell a
story with just pure movement and have
the audience feel a joy that he
displayed on screen was incredible I
wanted to do the same thing and I tried
to blend different styles and I try to
incorporate Gene's philosophies dance
now I had the pleasure to work on an
online series called the lxd short for
Legion of extraordinary dancers which
told stories through dance now we were
asked to perform on So You Think You Can
Dance you know that dance show that
comes on I used to come on after Glee
for Cle we wanted to show hip hop in a
new light just as Gene Kelly wanted to
showcase to the world that Ballet could
be masculine we wanted to showcase that
hip-hop can be beautiful we incorporated
classical string quartets with
hip-hop movement and it was amazing to
see the response and how we were able to
change people's perception of a dance
that's been around so long now we have
Jean to thank for that so he's also
influenced my work on Glee as a resident
dancer on the show any time had a soul I
needed the extra push I would ask myself
what would Jeannie do Gene Kelly changed
the way we look at dance and cinema
forever and I'm so so happy that his
legacy and work is still being
celebrated after all these years it's an
honor for me to share my story with you
and leave you with a funny quote that
Jean said that always makes me laugh
any man who looks like a [ __ ] while
dancing is just a lousy to answer thank
you so much